Welcome back to Google
Developers Weekly
for February 18th, 2014.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in the
world of Google Developers,
on the set and off.
We start off our recap with
something really quick,
as in QUIC UDP
internet connections,
a next generation
transport which
aims to reduce
latency and much more.
Web speed master
Ilya Grigorik helps
us learn how QUIC
works and tells
us what's around the corner
in this fast moving project.
We then welcome back Jarek
Wilkiewicz to the studio
to talk Freebase, a free
and open knowledge graph
with millions of entities.
Jarek and Dan
Brickley show you how
to experiment with
Freebase RDF data using
a prepackaged
distribution created
by Sindice Technologies.
Watch the event
and grab the image
at sindicetech.com/freebase.
We've entered Geotag with
a pair of Maps videos.
The first comes from
Maps magician Mano Marks,
who introduces two new
features found in Google Maps
SDK for iOS, gradient polylines
and reverse geocoding.
Then we're joined by engineering
interns Emma Yeap and Iris
Uy, who talk about the
Heatmaps library, a great way
to visualize large amounts
of geospatial data.
From New York, continuing his
crusade to bring all of you
coders a version 3 of
the YouTube data API,
Jeff Posnick is back, talking
about how quota is handled.
And should you want
to find out more,
you can always catch
up at youtube.com/dev.
For the last five weeks,
we've hosted Chris Wilson,
Sean Bennett, and Peter Lubbers
for the latest Office Hours
talking mobile web development
for the Udacity CS256 course.
This week's event takes
on lessons 10 through 12.
If you've missed it, we've
got more than CliffsNotes,
we've got everything for
your viewing pleasure.
Felipe Hoffa from the
Cloud platform team hosted
Pearson's Director of Data
Science, Collin Sellman .
The pair walked through how
Pearson uses data science
to improve education,
including Python and BigQuery.
Peng Ying and Mihai Ionescu,
two of my favorite Walleteers,
then walk through the Wallet
Objects API C# Quickstart
sample.
If you understood what that
meant, this show is for you.
And we wrapped up our
studio work this week
with the latest from
the Cast team, who
debuted the Cast
SDK for Android.
This video gives an
introduction on how
to build Google Cast center
applications for Android
using the Google Cast SDK.
There's lots of big news about
Google Cloud SQL this week.
First, Cloud SQL graduated
to general availability
with databases up
to 500 gigabytes.
Plus, data is now
automatically stored encrypted,
and there's a uptime
SLA of 99.95%.
And finally, you know those
pages with infinite scroll?
Maybe your site even
has some of them.
If so, you'll want
search engines
to crawl all that
infinite content.
For the best technique
on how to do this,
check out this week's blog
post on Google Developers Blog
at
googledevelopers.blogspot.com.
And to make sure that you never
miss a thing from the world
of Google Developers, subscribe
to Google Developers on YouTube
and check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll
see you in the studio.